The moment a baby is born, it is attacked
by several microbes present around.
But not all organisms are successful in their
attack.
However, the body does not
always win the battle either!
There are many infections which successfully
infect
us, irrespective of our age groups.
And not only this, but many a times it happens
that the same infection repeats its
occurrence!
Take the common cold for example!
It is one of the most common
infectious diseases caused by a virus known
as Rhinovirus.
And what do we mean by infectious disease?
The term “infectious” stands for
“liability of transmission”.
And the term “disease” literally means
the body is
“NOT AT EASE”.
So a Disease can be defined as an illness
caused by numerous factors, which
withholds the body from functioning normally.
There is one more concept similar to this,
which we need to know.
It is called
“Disorder”.
And what does that mean?
Well, the term literally means the body is
not able to work properly, or simply, is “out
of order”.
So are the two conditions
different?
Well, technically yes!
Diseases are mainly caused by pathogens.
That is, the external agents like viruses,
fungi, bacteria and so on, which enter the
body and create problems.
On the other hand, disorders are caused by
some or the other defects in the
functioning of certain cells or tissues.
Take diabetes for example.
It can occur due
to either improper production or improper
uptake of insulin by the cells.
Now, diseases are usually infectious or transmissible
whereas disorders are not!
There are many sources which use the term
“non-infectious diseases”
synonymously with “disorders”.
But what are these “non-infectious diseases”
by
the way?
Non-infectious diseases, as the name suggests,
are those diseases which do not
spread with mere contact.
So logically they can be used interchangeably.
But for now, we will not get into the details
of this classification of the types of
Diseases.
Rather, we will have a look at examples of
each type!
For studying infectious diseases in detail,
we will have a look at some known
diseases like Malaria, Typhoid and few others.
On the other hand, for studying disorders,
or say the non-infectious ones, we will
have a look at an important example like Cancer.
Let us have a look at each one in detail in
the upcoming videos!